[Music]
everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're gonna be
going over another trap and I'm actually
not sure the official name actually saw
it somewhere on the internet a while
back and actually played it myself a
couple days ago in a blitz game so it's
for black against the birds opening so
I'm just gonna call it the bird's eye
view you can actually know the name of
it go ahead and feel free to post or I'm
just going to call it the bird's eye
view trap so it starts out with white
opening in the birds opening with pawn
to f4 and blacks going through his bond
developing his Knight to f6 and why it's
going to continue with Knight to f3 and
blacks going to moves pawn to d6 and
here's really where you know you can
aside if you want to move forward a lot
of times you'll see white move his pawn
to e3 but if you don't a lot of times if
you move these six a lot of players is
they want to fianchetto on the coin side
you'll see them move
on to b3 getting ready to fianchetto
their Bishop on the queenside so from
here you can start to set the trap and
the trap looks like this it's pawn to e5
and obviously there's only one defender
of the e5 pawn and so white can safely
take and then recapture with this knight
so once white takes and black retakes
then white can safely take on e5 and now
black is going to develop his Bishop to
d6 attacking the knight on e5 now White
has two options and I would say 9 times
out of 10 they're gonna move back to f3
up a pawn and just try to develop as
normal obviously if they move Knight to
d3 it kind of hinders their ability to
develop their pieces and their pawns as
they're blocking there they're deep on
so a lot of times from here you'll
simply just see Knight to f3 and from
here we can bring our Knight to g4 and
this is actually a pretty devastating
move because white does not have a lot
of options there's a few things he can
do but not many are good from here if
they're not looking at all you may see
something as basic as pawn to h3 and
then simply black can come in and it's
checking that game over that easy now
they may completely ignore the whole
situation and move something like Bishop
to b2 and from here we can simply
capture on h2 and then let's say they
recapture with their knight then we can
simply bring our queen in and they only
have one move and that's to bring their
pawn to g3 and then we can recapture for
checkmate you may see them recapture
with their rook and then from here we
can recapture and they cannot recapture
with their Knight obviously if they
capture with their night then we can
come in and same story they're gonna
have to move their pawn to g3 and we can
easily checkmate
so from here they may try a different
move they can try to develop they can
they may move to g7 where we can just
move our rope to g8 but all in all we're
going to end up taking their Bishop on
f1 we're gonna be up in material and
their entire structure is going to be
completely messed up so White has the
option if they can mess up their whole
structure or get checkmate it pretty
easy and the game that actually played
ended up where they just move their pawn
to h3 and I just quickly came in and
checked made it on g3 and they never saw
it coming so if you see the birds
opening and you want to try this out I
think it's a pretty nifty trap so hope
you guys enjoyed I'll see you guys next
video